I welcome you to a talk on
the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah and
divided
this talk
into four sections. The first is
importance of
the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah.
The second is the important acts and
deeds to be done during the first 10
days of Dhul-Hijjah. The third is the
virtue of Arafah and the fourth is
Eid ul-Adha or Yawm un-Nahr.
First, we'll discuss
the importance of the first 10 days of
Dhul-Hijjah.
This
is a forgotten Sunnah of our beloved
Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam. You may have sinned all year.
You may have missed
doing good deeds in the month of
Ramadan.
You may have missed
the last 10 nights of Ramadan. You may
have missed doing good deeds during
Laylat al-Qadr.
This is your opportunity.
Make the best of it. The first 10 days
of Dhul-Hijjah. Even if you have not
sinned the whole year, maybe you did
some minor sins.
Maybe you did Ibadah in the month of
Ramadan. Even you might have got the
last 10 nights of Ramadan. Even you
might have prayed the full night of
Laylat al-Qadr. Yet,
you cannot afford as a Muslim
the opportunity
during the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah.
Most of us Muslims,
we are normally aware of the importance
of Ramadan and we prepare ourselves. And
I remember when I was a kid,
more than 30 years back, when I was in
school,
about 45 years back,
we used to prepare
ourselves for Ramadan and we knew the
importance of Ramadan, even of the last
10 nights of Ramadan. But, we never
heard
about the importance of the first 10
days of Dhul-Hijjah.
Alhamdulillah.
Now, since social media has started,
this is being discussed
by the speakers. My time when I was a
kid, when I was in school, when I just
entered college, we never heard the
speakers speaking about the importance
of 10 days of the Lija.
I remember the first time I heard was
maybe
about 15 years back in the social media.
When we got involved in the field of
Dawah,
about 25 30 years back, that's the time
we came to know about the importance of
the first 10 days of the Lija.
And it was about 15 years back that the
first time I heard in the social media a
speaker speaking about the importance of
the first 10 days of the Lija. And
alhamdulillah, year by year, it's
increasing and more and more people are
speaking about the importance of the
first 10 days of the Lija. That's the
reason I thought I will dedicate the
major portion of this session today to
the first 10 days of the Lija.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes an oath
in
Surah Fajr, chapter number 89, verse
number 1 to 2. Allah says, "Wal Fajr."
"Wal layalin ashr."
By Fajr, by dawn,
by the 10 nights.
And the mufassirin, they say these 10
nights that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
taking the oath of refers to the first
10 days of the Lija.
And in many languages,
when you speak about the days, it
includes the nights. When you speak
about the night, it includes the day.
For example, if I say in English, "I
spent 10 days in London."
But naturally, it includes I spent 10
days and 10 nights in London. Depending
upon the context, it include the full
day, it may include part of the day, it
may include the night, it may not
include. Similarly, when in Arabic the
nights are referred to
it may refer to the night only, it may
refer to the night and day put together,
or it may refer to the day only. In this
Surah Al-Fajr
Surah number 89, verse number 1 to 2
when Allah says, "Wal-Fajr
walayalin ashr."
By dawn.
By the 10 nights. The mufassirin say,
and it's also mentioned in Ibn Kathir
volume number eight, page number 413,
and if we refer to the summarized
version, the English translation
printed by Darussalam, it is volume
number 10
page number 468.
Ibn Kathir and many mufassirin say
that
these 10 nights refer
to the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah, and
they agree
that these
first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah are better
than all the other days of the year.
It's even better than the last 10 days
of Ramadan.
But
it's mentioned in Ibn Kathir
volume number five page number 412
that
though the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah
are the best days of the full year
the last 10 nights
of Ramadan are the best nights of the
year.
The scholars differ. Some scholars few
do say that
the first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah are
better than the last 10 nights of
Ramadan. There are few scholars who say
the last 10 nights are better than the
first 10 days of Dhul-Hijjah. But the
right opinion and the correct opinion is
by Ibn Taymiyyah, Shaykh al-Islam
may Allah have mercy on him and he
rightly said that the first 10 days of
Dhul-Hijjah are the is
in the full year. It is even better than
the last 10 days of Ramadan.
But,
the last 10 nights of Ramadan,
they are the best nights in the full
year
because it has the Laylat al-Qadr. It is
the best night in the full year. So, the
last 10 nights of Ramadan are the best
nights because it has Laylat al-Qadr.
And amongst the days in the full year,
the first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah are the
best days in the year because it has
the Yawm al-Arafah,
the day of Arafah.